a month ago my wife and i sold our
eight-figure software company and that
deal closed 30 days ago and so
what i wanted to share with you was
one of the the biggest and most profound
takeaways that i had from selling that
business and what we look at when we're
buying our own companies
if you guys don't know who i am i'm alex
from mozzie own acquisition.com or my
wife and i own acquisition.com our
portfolio does about 85 million a year
in revenue and i have nothing to sell
you
so what i want to talk about today is
one of the things that took me way too
long to realize in
looking at creating products and
ultimately you know buying and selling
businesses that that are valuable the
biggest piece or biggest takeaway that
i've had in creating quote fortunes
is understanding one concept it's so
simple to understand and so hard to do
the key
the one-way direction to creating a
fortune through business
is to only sell things that people do
not stop buying
i'll say it again the way to create a
fortune in business
is to only sell things that people do
not stop buying
some of you probably drink starbucks you
probably will not stop drinking
starbucks some of you drink coca-cola
and will probably not stop drinking
coca-cola some of you buy apple and will
probably not stop buying apple right
some of you watch netflix and will
probably never stop watching netflix
provided they just continue to do what
they're currently doing the thing that
is disheartening right and i'll say this
because i think it's it's just like
these are the obvious things that are so
obvious known does them right simple
scales fancy fails all right repeat
successful actions do the boring work
like these are sayings we have in our
community because
most of the success that i've had with
business has has not been from curing
cancer or inventing a new technology but
improving something to the point that
people want to continue to buy it and
continue to pay for it
and so right now this is the thought
experiment that if you're a small
business owner i would like you to do
if you were to write down
the total number of people that you have
ever sold
ever all time
and you were to tally that number up
and then you were to multiply that
by your current average monthly price
how much money would that be
probably a lot maybe a lot more than you
currently are making
the next thing to do is if that is the
amount of money that you were making
how much money would you have available
for you to spend in acquiring your
customers probably a lot
how convicted would you be
if every customer you sold you knew you
would not lose
probably vary
and so i think rather than thinking
about all the many tactics and there are
lots of them of making more money how do
i get more leads how do i optimize my
pricing how do i sell a higher
percentage all of that stuff right those
are a lot of the hand-to-hand combat and
i don't want to be mistaken here like
you can become a millionaire just
learning to be okay at those things
right if you just learn how to market
and sell you'll be able to make money
you won't be able to build a fortune but
you will be able to make money the thing
is
is that if you can optimize around the
single question which is
what is something that i can sell that
people will never stop buying it after
they start
and how do i structure the thing in such
a way that the value they're getting is
so far in excess of what they're paying
me that they never want to leave that
they call me when their credit card goes
down to make sure that they continue to
stay and pay so right now many of you
probably with your wi-fi right if your
wi-fi went out because your car didn't
go through you would probably
immediately update your card and get the
wi-fi back up if your phone service went
down you would immediately update your
card and get it back going if you if
your netflix got canceled you do the
same thing right and that is because we
value those services far in excess of
the price there is what is called a
customer surplus which means you are
getting far more than what you pay for
and so you feel like you're not only
getting a good deal you're getting a
crazy deal and so you never want to stop
buying it because the value exchange is
so far in your favor
and so
when i am now looking at businesses i am
seeing what the overall opportunity is
that we're pursuing and what the main
value proposition is and i'm thinking to
myself so i'm just giving you the mental
frameworks that i'm working with which
is
how can i turn this thing that is
valuable into something that someone
will never want to stop buying all right
so there's a couple of frameworks that i
will that i'll walk you through
this is probably the most this is for a
b2b scenario but you can probably apply
to anything many times there are
especially like the e-learning space
people will sell a method which i think
by the way is silly because people will
never stop they will they'll definitely
buy the method and then never need the
method right
which is why i prefer models to methods
right a model can have lots of methods
that feed into it but a method can only
it's like a one one and done right and
so ideally you want to transition your
business from a method selling business
to a model selling business because then
you will have a model that can always
evolve over time franchises sell models
and the marketing will change it was
groupon then it was email
but it was facebook ads and instagram
ads and youtube ads and all the things
that have happened since right media
will change but the model will remain
the same and so if the model is
something that someone used to continue
to have then that's something that they
will not get rid of right now in the in
the netflix video that i made like how i
crack recurring revenue there's eight
c's that i look at to make something
stickier all of those things will
increase the stick but the biggest one
by far is the simple customer surplus
the value discrepancy in what you sell
uh sorry what you deliver and the price
that you charge for it right and most
people try and cut the prices in order
to get there when in reality we should
be increasing the value so that rather
like you can create a customer surplus
by lowering the price so much the thing
is is there's not a lot of profit left
over and you won't have a big business
and so unless you have something that
causes zero dollars to reproduce um you
know like
there's dropbox right virtually zero
dollars to reproduce more storage
then it's very difficult to do something
like that right the idea if you want to
create a fortune is to think
consistently how can i make this so that
no one stops buying and in the software
world which i highly recommend you
look at all the writers for business in
software because software is software as
a service right sas all right now that
means that all the metrics and all the
things that they have quantitatively
been able to measure in software as a
service 100 applies to service because
it's just software doing the job that
service is supposed to be doing and so
if we can do that right if we can if we
can quantitate it in this way quantify
in this way then this is the this is the
three-step process that they go through
when they're trying to create a
billion-dollar unicorn company all right
and i got this from mark roberge who was
the one of the one of the early guys in
uh in hubspot right i think he took them
from zero to 100 million and now he's a
lecturer at harvard all right this is
the process that they go through
the first step
is is is getting enough promotion so
that you can get customers all right he
said we're not worried about pricing
we're not worried about value we need to
be priced high enough that people will
care but not so high that we're trying
to maximize profit because that's not
the goal of this period of time right
now this unfortunately is where most of
the internet marketing community stops
they learn how to promote and they think
that that's how they're going to make
money but that's not you'll make some
money but you won't build a fortune that
way right so the promotion period is
simply to get customers all right you
make sales to get customers you're not
getting making customers to get sales
all right very important distinction and
so when we do that the idea is that
we're continually testing the product
until we get to the point where people
don't leave and in theory we should
never really leave here until we have
figured this piece out
once we have figured this piece out
then
we can start scaling it right and so if
you're thinking about this in sequence
it's promotion which is usually zero to
a million product which is one to ten
million which is where you're you're
optimizing your product so that people
never want to leave they never want to
stop buying and then once you have
something where the product is such that
people don't stop buying all of your
marketing efforts in and of themselves
will start compounding because people
won't leave and so it's just like you've
got this glue and you're blowing all
this traffic at this glue and it just
sticks and it just keeps and if you
never lose a customer you will literally
never stop making more money year over
year
think about that just like
hypothetically just think about that for
a second you will never stop making
money you will never stop making more
money year over year if you never lose a
customer and i think that it's just such
a profound like ideology shift it's so
easy to say and so hard to do which is
why most people don't want to do it but
if you're part of mozi nation and you
like doing the the boring work you like
doing the things that other people are
not willing to do
then these are the things these are the
keys to the kingdom is creating things
that people will never stop buying and
that means that you're interviewing
customers it means you're surveying them
it means you're looking at usage
patterns you're looking at the things
that they're consuming you're looking at
how you can increase the collateral
within your community so that people
don't want to leave and we do these
things over and over and over again
until we get to the point we're at one
percent two percent monthly churn at
most rather than um you know 10 or 20
which is what most people have and if
that sounds hard of course it is but the
thing is is that i guarantee you that no
one else is doing it everyone's
obsessing about their stripe account
screenshots but the thing is is that the
fortunes
are not even made in the follow-up the
fortunes are made to never losing
customers because then you have time on
your side because then over a long
enough time horizon even if you suck at
marketing people will find out about
your product over a long enough time
horizon and if you have a product that
people never stop using you will be able
to make a tremendous amount of money
because in 20 years if you were to think
about whatever amount of sales you have
right now as a small business owner you
might have been doing this for three
years or five years whatever it is right
if you were to multiply this in your 20
years into your career and you've
actually been doing the same thing one
it would be far more likely that you'd
have something that you would have
figured out how to make the product so
good that people wouldn't wouldn't leave
but also
20 years from now you'd have so many
customers even if you weren't that good
at promotion that your business would be
gigantic all right and so i i think i've
told this story before but i had a i had
a
a consulting engagement that i did years
ago where somebody was selling the exact
same amount of clients as i was and they
were making 300 000 a month and we were
doing 4 million a month
and i think i had 100 times the profit
of their company
and it wasn't because they were like we
were selling the same amount of
customers it was just that we had such a
better monetization view with such a
better product we were able to deliver
so much more value that we were able to
grow to a much bigger size like if you
sell 100 clients a month b2b you should
be able to build that into into a 100
million dollar enterprise you have the
sales velocity and so then it's just
simply and i know that's like well what
about pricing over a long enough time
horizon you should still probably if
you're b2b you'll probably be at you
know in a price point where you would
get there if here's the big if you don't
lose customers and so i think the vast
majority if there's one message from
this video it's
what can we look at or reimagine within
our customer experience and the product
that we deliver that will deliver
outsized returns so that we have a
customer surplus which means the amount
of value provide is far excess to the
price that we charge and that doesn't
matter what the price is so when someone
says i charge high ticket i think it's a
silly silly concept altogether right
because it really should just be high
value that's the real concept which is
high value all right because what is
expensive right if i said hey i'll give
you my you know my lambo for 20 grand is
that a good deal absolutely right price
is what you pay value is what you get
and that discrepancy is going to be the
customer surplus and so right now if i
said that to this channel hey i need the
first person who wires me 20 grand right
gets the lambo a lot of people would
probably wire me 20 grand right because
the value is clear to understand if i
was selling a house and i said hey give
me you know it's a 500 000 house give it
to you for 50 grand it's a great deal
most people would make that offer and so
the thing is is that that is what the
business like that is where fortunes are
built is finding a way to build a house
for less than fifty thousand dollars to
build a five hundred thousand dollar
house
build it for ten thousand dollars build
it for five thousand dollars and sell it
for fifty thousand dollars that's the
game that we're trying to play that is
where fortunes are made that is where
fortunes are founded that is where you
sell things that people will never stop
buying and that is the real key to
making more wealth and more money than
you know what to do with and the reality
is it's very simple to say and very hard
to do and that's why most people will
never be wealthy but you are part of
mozi nation and you are not going to be
one of those people uh because we do the
boring work we do the things that people
are not willing to do so that we can
have success that they have never
dreamed of so anyways keep being awesome
if you enjoyed this my name is austin
mosey on acquisition.com um we do 85
million dollars in revenue and i have
absolutely nothing to sell you like i
said if you like this hit the subscribe
button we have a lot more tactical
videos on how to grow your business um
and if you uh if you didn't like this
then i love you either way keeping
awesome because you're in the game and i
will always appreciate you for that so
keep being awesome catch you soon bye